après tant de déboires c'est ce geste
simple que chloé 28 ans attendait avec
impatience pour ouvrir enfin les portes
de son petit bar à tapas lancé en 2018
si elle a fait un peu de vente à
emporter ces dernières semaines mais
rien ne remplace le retour tant attendu
des clients on avait hâte de revenir
j'avais hâte de revenir devant les
clients aujourd'hui
donc là il est 17h37 je suis prête avant
l'heure il le fallait donc je suis très
contente
18h les premiers clients arrivent enfin
dans son bar à la capacité restreinte
sans terrasse
mais sa grille à la même chose patricia
et annabelle sont des habitués du lieu
ce retour elle aussi l'attendait c'est
avec plaisir et presque comme un acte
citoyen quelles sont revenus c'est
important de déjà de ravoir une vie
sociale et de faire travailler les
commerçants aussi voilà les petits
entrepreneurs comme chloé qui se donne
du mal tous les jours et qui après 70
jours de fermeture ont certainement des
difficultés je venais fatema fait ici
lundi 7 mars
ça a été loupée g unit fêter mon
anniversaire le 29 mai ça a été loupée
donc c'est obligé que je revienne
aujourd'hui l'ambiance est légère même
si le protocole sanitaire est bien
présent pour cette soirée de reprise
une dizaine de clients sont venus ils
étaient tendres et ouvrir puisque
l'activité vins c'est vraiment stopper
net et pendant une période assez longue
donc on est content de pouvoir se
relancer je pense qu'avec mes confrères
c'était important qu'on revienne
et puis qu'on reparte de plus belle et
j'espère que les clients vont répondre
présents également cet été pour venir
nous voir
m quelques tables dehors pouvoir
accueillir plus de monde
chloé débordant vie et espère que l'été
lui redonnent des couleurs
[Musique]